Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag. Aktaş ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf der Kurs des Kurs.
Als Assistentin und ich mit Ihnen führen.
Ja, sehr gerne, Doktor.
Bevor wir genau über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen,
bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Roman Herzog.
Roman, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Nachnamen ist Herzog.
H-E-R-Z-O-G.
Der Vorname ist Roman.
R-O-M-A-N.
Alles klar.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herzog?
Ich bin jetzt 35 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m war ich mal.
Mein Gewicht ist ungefähr 95 bis 97 m.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Doktor Müller.
Haben Sie eine Gehörige, die wir benachrichtigen sollen?
Ich kann Ihnen die Nummer von meiner Mutter geben,
wenn Sie möchten, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das notwendig ist.
Es ist notwendig, später.
Herr Herzog, was führt Sie zu uns?
Eigentlich schickt mich der Hausarzt,
bei dem wir eigentlich gewesen waren.
Aber der ist mir nicht kompetent genug
und hat nichts zu unternommen.
Ich habe ihn aufgesucht,
weil ich schon seit längerer Zeit mit Kopfschmerzen zu tun habe.
Ich habe auch Schlafstörungen.
Dann kommt es vor, dass ich abkühle.
Man habe ich auch Herzklopfen.
Ich bin etwas nervöser in den letzten Wochen und Monat.
Herzklopfen und Sie fühlen sich nervös.
Hauptprobleme sind die Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe sich morgens aufgehend.
Meistens morgens haben Sie auch.
Manchmal auch tagsüber, aber morgens wenn ich aufstehe.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Die habe ich schon eine ganze Zeit.
Stärk geworden, in den letzten 3-4 Wochen.
Seit 3-4 Wochen.
Wann sind die Beschwerden aufgezählt?
Das ist sicher schon über ein Jahr her.
Ich hatte immer wieder Kopfschmerzen.
Ein Jahr.
Die andere Beschwerden, wie z.B.
Windlich, Schlafstörung, haben alle Beschwerden zusammen angefangen?
Oder erst mal Kopfschmerzen und dann später andere Beschwerden?
Die anderen Beschwerden sind auch nicht immer da.
Manchmal habe ich das im Haushalts-LZ, weil ich gefragt habe,
ob ich irgendwelche anderen Beschwerden habe.
Die sind nicht immer da und sind auch nicht immer gleichzeitig da.
Manchmal habe ich auch Schwindel, aber ich kann auch mal Schwindel haben.
Ohne Ohrensausen, Herzklopfen habe ich auch nicht immer.
Das ist nicht immer gleich.
Gibt es etwas, was die Beschwerden verschlimmert oder lindert?
Habe ich jetzt nicht so festgestellt,
dann kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Hast du einen Auslöser nicht bemerkt?
Nicht so richtig.
Sind die Beschwerden abhängig von Essen oder Bewegung?
Kommen sie in Ruhe auch?
Kommen sie auch in Ruhe.
Und unabhängig von Essen?
Habe ich jetzt auch keinen Bezug festgestellt,
ich kann nicht sagen.
Könntest du bitte Kopfschmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen klopfend, drückend?
Oder gibt es eine Punkt, bestimmte Punkte?
Meistens in Hinterkopfbereichen, die sind eher dumpf.
Hinterkopfbereichen?
Okay.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Vielleicht ein bisschen in Nacken, aber eigentlich nicht so richtig.
Kann ich nicht sagen, also hauptsächlich im Kopf.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10?
Also 0 bis gar nicht 10 ist ganz schlimm.
5 bis 6, würde ich sagen.
5 bis 6.
Okay.
Und haben Sie auch Selbststörung?
Habe ich nicht, nein.
Und Sie haben Herzklopfen?
Nicht immer, also kommt mal vor, aber auch nicht regelmäßig und auch nicht jeden Tag.
Fühlen Sie sich auch müde?
Ja, weil ich habe halt Schlafstörung, also ich schlafe nicht durch, also ich war immer wieder aufnachts.
Schlafstörung wegen Schmerzen oder weil Sie nervös sind?
Weiß ich nicht, beides vielleicht.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich wohne hier an einer lauten Straße, also das ist so eine Stadtautobahn,
wo ich hier wohne, das ist hier vom Balkonhaus direkt, da kann man drauf gucken, da habe ich auch immer,
ist auch laut, vielleicht liegt es auch daran, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Und wie viel Stunden jeden Tag können Sie schlafen?
Also wenn man natürlich die Unterbrechung jetzt mitzählt, vielleicht schon so 6, 7 Stunden,
weil ich mit vielen Unterbrechungen höre.
Können Sie beim Schlafen flach liegen oder brauchen Sie mehrere Kissen?
Nein, ich kann flach liegen, aber wenn ich morgens aufdehe, merke ich,
dass die Kopfschmerzen besser werden, wenn ich dann Kissen nehme, also wenn die Kopfhöhe ist,
dann ist es manchmal ein bisschen besser, das habe ich festgestellt.
Okay.
Wenn Sie Ihre Kopfformen beugen, sind die Schmerzen stärker?
Also jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel keine Schmerzen, also es kommt manchmal vor.
Und treten die Beschwerden plötzlich oder schleichen?
Also ich würde schon sagen, plötzlich, also wenn ich morgens aufdehe, habe ich die manchmal,
also auch nicht jeden Morgen muss ich sagen.
Und wie lange gedauert die Beschwerden, die Schmerzen und andere Beschwerden,
wie lange gedauert?
Halbe Stunde.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen etwas, Schmerzmittel?
Habe ich auch schon gemacht, die helfen schon ein bisschen, aber ich versuche,
mir ist es kein Schmerzmedikamente zu nehmen, weil ich, also es schnickt man den Magen auch.
Okay.
Meistens nehmen Sie keine Medikamente?
Versuche ich ohne Medikamente, ja.
Und ob Sie keine Medikamente nehmen, gehen die Schmerzen...
Manchmal auch, ja, alleine wieder weg, ja.
Okay, aber wenn Sie Schmerzen, Tablette nehmen, hilft das?
Ja, hilft auch, ja.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Selbststörungen.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden,
wer ist wirklich diese Beschwerden?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe jetzt vergessen zu sagen, der Hausarzt hat mich geschickt,
weil er Blutdruck gemessen hat.
Und er sagt, das ist zu hoch, also er hat gemessen 150 zu 95,
ich muss ins Kragenhaus.
Aber er hat sich auch jetzt nicht drum gekümmert, muss ich sagen.
Also einmal gemessen, dann hat er gleich Kragenhaus,
er hat jetzt keine Zeit für weitere Untersuchungen.
Da soll sich der Kollegen Kragenhaus drum kümmern.
Wenn waren Sie bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Ja, heute Mittag, ja.
Heute Mittag.
Und Bluthochdruck war erst einmal heute festgestellt?
Also bisher ist das nicht bekannt bei mir.
Und könntest du Sie wiederholen, wie hoch Baden-Bürtdruck?
150 zu 95.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim normalen, bei den Treppensteigen?
Bekommen Sie Luftnot?
Eigentlich nicht, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten?
Haben Sie Fieber bemerkt in Letzte-Seite?
Nein, ich hatte keine Fieber.
Nachtschweiß?
Auch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Letzte-Seite Gewicht ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe konstantes Gewicht seit mehreren Jahren.
Wie ist Ihr Zugang?
Normal, würde ich sagen, habe ich keine Schwierigkeiten.
Kein Durchfall?
Nein, kein Durchfall.
Okay.
Und was erlassen, wie sieht es aus?
Ich habe auch keine Probleme, Doktor.
Treiben Sie Sport, Herr Herzog?
Leider nicht, nein.
Früher, ganz früher, aber als über 15 Jahren habe ich keinen Sport mehr gemacht.
Okay.
Sie waren heute bei Ihr Hausarzt.
Ein Bluthochdruck wurde festgestellt.
Gibt es noch andere Ergebnisse?
War andere alles normal beim Untersuchung?
Er hat mich gar nicht untersucht.
Er hat mich gleich Überweisung geben.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen oder haben Sie Vorerkrankungen gehabt?
Also chronische Erkrankungen habe ich keine Vorerkrankungen.
Bei mir sind da Gallensteine festgestellt worden, aber da habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Vorerkrankungen, ich bin mal als Jugendlicher am Blindarm.
Ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen gehabt.
Für Gallensteine nehmen Sie etwas, eine Medikamente?
Nein.
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Sonst nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Ich nehme manchmal Pantopazol,
und ich habe dann Magenhaversapf und so.
Ich habe dann Magen, Sortbrennen und Sortbrennen.
Sortbrennen.
Das kommt vor, das ist dann eine Tablette.
Seit wann haben Sie Radstarm oder Sortbrennen?
Ist das Gastritis?
Es ist jetzt nicht geguckt worden, aber da habe ich schon gemerkt,
wenn ich auf der Arbeit Stress habe,
als Lehrer in der Schule.
Ich habe dann gemerkt,
dass da ein Magen reagiert.
Ich habe keine Magenspielung gehabt.
Keine Magenspielung?
Was ich noch erwähnen darf,
ich war auch mal zum Checkup vor ein paar Jahren.
Der Blutzucker war gleich erhöht gewesen.
Als der Haus hat gesagt,
müsste man überwachen.
Aber einmal 160 gewesen.
Das kann man nach dem Essen sein.
Aber bis zum Weiterbeobachten.
Und Kohlesterin Wertheber auch?
Er war knapp über 300 gewesen.
Ich musste gucken,
dass ich meine Ernährung umstelle.
Wie hoch?
Über 210.
Alles klar.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nur als Jugendlicher als Kind.
Sie haben schon gesagt, okay.
Alles klar.
Rachen Sie?
Leider ja.
Seit wann und wie viel rachen Sie?
Seit dem Studium ungefähr.
15 Jahre bestimmt schon.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Wie viele Zigaretten rachen Sie am Tag?
Halbes Päckchen bis ein Päckchen.
Manchmal vor, dass ein Päckchen rauf wäre.
Trinken Sie?
Alkohol?
Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also nicht regelmäßig, gelegentlich.
Wenn ich in Gesellschaft bin beim Essen,
dann habe ich nicht jeden Tag.
Ein paar Mal in Monat?
Ja, ein, zwei Mal in der Woche.
Und was trinken Sie?
Das unterschiedliche Bier, Wein.
Alles klar.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ja, einmal.
Aber schon lange im Studium.
Das war nur einmal.
Einmal.
Was war das, Drogen?
Das war, Mario Hanna war das gewesen.
Aber wir haben einmal nur geraucht.
Einmal probiert es sonst nicht.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen allergin bekannt?
Keine allergen.
Wenn Sie Drogen sagen, ich weiß nicht,
gehört Kaffee auch zu Drogen, weil ich trinke viel Kaffee.
Nein, das ist nur ein Genusmittel.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es Bekannte für Erkrankungen,
chronische Erkrankungen, die zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck ist nicht bekannt.
Also mein Vater ist,
der war nicht so alt, der gestorben ist,
der Lungenkrebs, der lag gebaucht.
Aber Bluthochdruck war bei ihm nicht gewesen.
Meine Mutter hat Zucker
und hat auch noch so eine rheumatische Erkrankung Lupus.
Lupus.
Und hat noch zwei Geschwister, also eine Schwester,
die hat auch so eine rheumatische Erkrankung.
Und der Bruder, der hat als Kind schon Diabetes gehabt.
Als Kind also insulinpflichtet?
Ja, der musste als Kind schon Insulin spritzen.
Und Ihre Mutter, ist das auch...
Das ist im Alter dieses Buchs.
Und Ihre Mutter lebt noch?
Ja, lebt noch.
Und Ihr Vater, wie alt war er,
wenn er gestorben war?
Er war Anfang 62,
62.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Herzog?
Nein, ich bin Single.
Okay. Leben Sie allein?
Ich lebe allein.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Welche Fach?
Geschichte und Deutsch.
Und...
Haben Sie viel Stress oder schüpeln Sie?
Fühlen Sie sich unter emotionalen Belastung?
Wie ist der Arbeitsleben?
Ja, ist schon stressig für mich.
Also ich habe auch manchmal auch keine Kraft.
Also ich bin ausgelockt und habe auch mal Krank-Tage,
Fehl-Tage, wenn ich zugelastet bin.
Also das ist schon stressiger Beruf, finde ich.
Okay. Fühlen Sie sich manchmal antwürztlos?
Oder sehr...
Sie fühlen sich schon müde, aber...
Ja, kommt manchmal vor, aber nicht extrem.
Extrem, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist...
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Zum Beispiel gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona bin ich geimpft.
Als die Pandemie war, dann auch nicht mehr.
Wie viele Mal?
Da drei Mal habe ich damals gearbeitet.
Kindheit, Krankheiten?
Da war ich geimpft, vollständig.
Und wissen Sie, ob Sie gegen, zum Beispiel,
Maninjitis oder Neumoney geimpft sind?
Das... also zumindest nicht in den letzten Jahren.
Ich weiß nicht.
Als Kind, weiß ich, und wenn das macht als Kindere.
Also erwachsen habe ich da kein Impfung bekommen.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Herr Herzog, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht.
Er hat mich zweitens kracken ausgeschickt,
aber muss ich deswegen diese Sachen jetzt im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Und dann kann man das jetzt in die Ambulanz,
Arbeiter abklären, was denken Sie?
Ja.
Wir müssen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und bevor alle Befunde haben,
können wir nicht genau sagen.
Aber momentan, Sie haben das,
Sie haben das, was Sie haben,
momentan, Sie müssen für die Ergebnisse
hier im Station bleiben.
Und nach der Ergebnisse können wir genau sagen,
ob wir müssen, Sie stationieren müssen.
Oder das ist noch nicht klar.
Okay.
Wie lange dauern die Ergebnisse, was meinen Sie?
Ich denke, heute können wir ein paar Ergebnisse bekommen.
Und danach können wir genau über Ihre Diagnose sprechen.
Ich müsste wissen, damit ich hier Bescheid sagen kann,
der Schule, damit die für morgen Ersatzlehrer organisieren können.
Ja, aber es ist wahrscheinlich,
dass Sie stationär bleiben müssen.
Dann sage ich am besten schon mal ab.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut, das waren meine Fragen, Dr. Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Oder Ergänzen?
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Keine Übelkeit.
Medikamenten an dem Näsis,
war das nachgefragt?
Ja, ich würde noch mal so empfehlen,
dass man noch mal geziet nach anderen Medikamenten fragt.
Hat er glaube ich aber als Fennein so was?
Medikamentenanlebnis, ich denke schon,
ich habe gefragt.
Okay.
Herzog, schnarchen Sie beim Klatschen?
Weiß ich nicht, ich hör mich selbst nicht.
Haben Ihre Freunde etwas darüber gesagt?
Also meine Freunde übernachten nicht bei mir,
deswegen haben sie bis jetzt nichts dazu gesagt.
Okay, und haben Sie am Morgen Stalken am Mund bemerkt?
Nicht übermäßig, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Okay, danke.
Gut.
Ich denke, eine wichtige Frage gestattet.
Eine Sache, die ich noch gefragt habe.
Was macht Bluthochdruck?
Oh, ja, ja, bitte.
Es sind sehr sassige Sachen,
schnarchen oder speischen.
Sehr gerne, ja.
Was macht noch Bluthochdruck, wenn man zu viel ist?
Wie viel ist der Blutdruck?
1,45 bis 1,95.
150 zubereit, außer...
Sie haben gesagt, ich trinke gerne Kaffee.
Wie viel Kaffee trinken Sie pro Tag?
4,5 Kassen Kaffee.
Danke.
Haben Sie eine Schwäche in Ihrem Armen oder Beinen bemerkt?
Oder erfüllen Sie sich kribbeln in Ihrem Körper?
Kribbeln?
Oder amaisenlaufen?
Hat er nicht gehabt, nein.
Was gibt es noch für Nahrungsmittel,
die bei übermäßigem Verzehr zu Durchfall führen können,
aber auch zu Bluthochdruck?
Mir ist der türkische Name jetzt gerade entfallen für diese Sache.
Welche?
Schneckenform.
Kennen Sie das?
Ja, ich habe...
Lackritze?
Süßigkeit.
Ja.
Süßigkeit, aber was gibt drin?
Ich weiß nicht, was Lackritze drin ist.
Ich überlege gerade auch, wie das auf Türkisch heißt.
Merenkügelmus.
Also das ist mal so in den Lehrbüchern drin.
Lackritze, wie das kann durchmachen, zum Beispiel auch aber.
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Okay, gut.
Und das andere haben Sie gefragt, mit Kaffee, Alkoholkonsum, Tabakkonsum, das sind auch so.
Was gibt es denn für Risikofaktoren für Bluthochdruck?
Hat der welche der Patient?
Genetisch, ja Hintergrund.
Genetisch, ja.
Was gibt es noch für Risikofaktoren, die nicht genetisch sind?
Übergewicht.
Genau, hat er auch, ja.
Kein Sport macht.
Bewegungsmangel, richtig.
Aber uns in nächster Zeit die Stress durchstellt?
Ja, der gesagt, der hat durchgehend Stress in der Schule, ja.
Was zählt aber auch noch als Stress?
Da hat er in seiner Angabe etwas genannt, was mittlerweile auch als Risikofaktor
für Bluthochdruck von der BHO anerkannt ist.
Ein Stressfaktor von außen, nicht psychischer Stress oder indirekt,
aber was hat er gesagt?
Rana hat geschrieben, ich per Kondition.
Ja, das hat er auch.
Das ist auch noch ein Risikofaktor, was hat er gesagt, wo er wohnt?
Haben Sie mal noch überlegt?
Er lebt allein, vielleicht Ernährung ist nichts so gesund.
Ja, aber fast tot oder?
Er hat etwas gesagt, wo er wohnt.
Ah ja, in...
Und in der Sendung?
Viel Geräusche gibt es.
Also Lärm ist ein Risikofaktor für Bluthochdruck mittlerweile anerkannt
und auch Luftverschmutzung oder Belastung ist auch Risikofaktor
von der BHO anerkannt als Bluthochdruck.
Schlafstörungen, ja, Risikofaktor auch.
Schlafstörungen.
Bitte?
Schlafstörungen auch Risikofaktor, ja, Schlafstörungen.
Also Schlafstörungen für Bluthochdruck,
ich glaube, das ist die Folge von dem Hochdruck gewesen bei ihm.
Und bewusst hohe Werte hatten, dass er dadurch immer aufgewacht ist.
Das ist, glaube ich, der Mechanismus gewesen, ja.
Okay.
Können wir als Erzatsgespräch anfangen?
Ja, bitte.
Bitte schön, Söder.
Ja.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt.
Hallo.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Herr Roman Herzog.
Er ist 35 Jahre alt, 1,78 m, 95 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns vor,
mit seit 3, 4 Wochen bestehenden Kopfschmerzen.
Die Kopfschmerzen befinden sich hinter dem Kopf meistens begleitet von Schlafstörungen,
schwindelig, ohrensausend Herzklopfen und er fühlt sich nervös.
Okay.
Entschuldigung, wenn ich fragen darf, da wo ich hin darf.
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Sie sagen hinter dem Kopf, also am Hinterkopf oder hinter dem Kopf?
Hinterkopf.
Ja, occipitalisch.
Schmerzen am Hinterkopf.
Hinterkopf, ja.
Hinterkopf.
Diese Beschwerden sind schon ein Jahr aufgetreten,
aber seit 3, 4 Wochen zugenommen haben.
Er war heute Morgen beim Hausarzt.
Der Hausarzt hat einen Hochblutdruck festgestellt.
Hier hast du 95 und hier 150.
Auf diesem Grund hat der Hausarzt zu uns überwiesen.
Der Patient hat...
Entschuldigung, mit welcher Verdachziagnose?
Warum hat er ihn geschickt jetzt?
Wegen Bluthochdruck.
Nur Bluthochdruck bei Hochblutdruck.
Ja, Bluthochdruck ist eine Volkskrankheit.
Da muss man jetzt nicht Patienten in den Kranken ausschicken, oder?
Ja, aber der Hausarzt hat keine andere Befund gefunden.
Na gut, ok, können wir gleich mal besprechen.
Ich habe gefragt, ob eine Diagnose festgestellt wurde,
aber keine Diagnose sind vorhanden.
Also müssen wir den Patienten aufnehmen?
Ich würde den Patienten jetzt nicht aufnehmen.
Mit Bluthochdruck soll er Haushaltsdien anstellen.
Ja, aber es gibt nicht nur Bluthochdruck,
es gibt noch einen, der Herzklopfen.
Er hat Schlafstörungen.
Er hat Schwindel.
Es ist in Schwindel.
Gut oder ist es chronisch?
Ja, es ist chronisch.
Aber da müssen Sie nicht aufnehmen, oder?
Warum muss man jetzt ein Patient mit Herzklopfen und Kopfschmerzen aufnehmen?
Wir haben sowieso keine Betten, oder?
Sehen Sie das anders?
Machen Sie ein paar Basisuntersone und schicken Sie nach Hause?
Soll Hausarzt sich drum kümmern?
Das ist kein Grund, warum ein Patient in die Stadt zu nehmen werden muss.
Ja, aber wir müssen erstmal neurologische Krankheiten ausschließen.
Bei jedem Patienten, der mit Kopfschmerzen in die Notaufnahme kommt,
wenn sie da neurologische Abklärung machen müssen,
dann können sie den Laden zumachen.
Sie müssen ein bisschen gucken, wenn sie die Stadt zu nehmen,
die müssen wir ihnen nicht.
Wir machen eine neurologische Untersuchung.
Ob es eine Lehmung oder eine Selbststörung gibt.
Wenn es kein Befund gibt, dann machen Sie noch EKG,
dass wir gucken, ob er ein Problem hat.
Das ist ein Basislabor, wenn das in Ordnung ist,
dann schicken Sie wieder zum Hausarzt zurück,
damit das weiter abklärt.
Was meinen Sie?
Ich denke, diese Beschwerden,
vielleicht meine Verdachtdiagnose,
ist Schlafabne, Schlafabnesyndrom.
Begel Schlafabne kann diese Beschwerden auftreten.
Kann sein.
Aber es kann auch eine Gehirntumor sein.
Wir müssen auch eine benignene.
Da sollen Sie das mal neurologisch,
dann können Sie entscheiden, ob Sie noch mal neurologisch abklären müssen.
Was hat noch für Probleme?
Das gibt es noch für mich.
Begründete Anamnese war unauffällig.
An Vorerfrankungen hat er Koleliteasis ohne Beschwerden,
ohne Behandlung.
Als er 13 Jahre alt war,
wurde eine Epandectomy durchgeführt.
Er wurde unter Sort gebrannt.
Dafür nahm er Phantoprosol.
Aber keine Magenstügelung wurde durchgeführt.
Früher hat Hausarzt
eine Hyperglykozeme gesucht.
180.
Die hohe Kohlosterin-Werte,
also die Hyperkohlosterin-Werte,
wurde gesucht.
Er ist rach.
Er ist seit 15 Jahren
mit den 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Er trinkt gelegenzige Alkohol.
Er hat als Jung-Jugend Mariana Gerav probiert.
Es gibt keine Allergen.
Er trinkt viel Kaffee.
Er trinkt 3-4 Tasse jeden Tag.
Bei der Familienanahmnese ergibt sich,
dass der Vater im Alter von 62 an Nungenkrebs gestorben ist.
Die Mutter hat Diabetes meines Tips,
die sie mit Lupus.
Ihre Schwester leidet unter rheumatologisches Krankheit.
Ihr Bruder hat Diabetes meines Tips.
In der Sozialanahmnese ergibt sich,
dass er Single ist und lebt allein.
Er ist Lehrer von Beruf und hat Stress bei der Arbeit.
Er lebt in einer Wohnung, wo viel Larm gibt.
Das macht auch Stress.
Vielleicht stört er ihm und kann er nicht gut schlafen.
Er ist vollständig geimpft 3-mal gegen Corona.
Reiseanahmnese ist unauffällig.
Aufgrund der anahmnestischen Angaben ergibt sich der Verdacht
auf eine Schlafabnö-Syndrom.
Diese Beschwerden wie Bluthoffdruck,
Schlafstörung, Kopfschmerzen, Nervosität, Müdigkeit,
sprechen sich für eine Schlafabnö-Syndrom.
Differenzialdiagnostisch,
kommen Gehirn, Pummel,
oder auch vielleicht eine chronische Kopfschmerzen
wie Migran oder Cluster-Typ.
Also wegen Stress.
Stress kann auch diese Beschwerden verursachen.
Um so weitere Abklärung,
werde ich den Patienten förderlich untersuchen.
Danach nehme ich Blut ab.
Schauen Sie in Blut.
T-Hormon ist wichtig.
Ich habe eine Schlafstörung, Nervosität,
T-Hormon, T-H, T3, T4.
Routinemäßig kann ich wissen, ob es eine Anämie gibt.
Anämie macht auch, oder verursacht, Kopfschmerzen,
Müdigkeit, Herzklopfen,
kann auch wegen einer Anämie bestehen.
Als bildgebende Untersuchung
würde ich gegebenenfalls eine MRT vorschlagen,
für eine Gehirn-Tummel auszuschließen.
Das kann man alles machen.
Wir haben ja jetzt keine Kapazitäten für eine Patientenaufnahme.
Gucken Sie nach.
Wenn er neurologisch unaufwändig ist,
dann schicken Sie ihn nach Hause.
Dann können Sie dem Hausarzt die Sachen empfehlen.
Für mich ist dieser Patient ein normaler Patient.
Viele Menschen sprechen viel von der Anämie.
Ob es eine Schlafabdnöse ist,
kann man einen Screening-Test machen.
Ansonsten schicken Sie ihn nach Hause.
Wenn es eine Hypertonie ist,
kann man Antipersensiv und Betabloka behandeln.
Ist eine Hypertonie überhaupt?
Ist einmal ein Blutdruck von 150 zu 90 gleich eine Hypertonie?
Nein, wir müssen ein paar Wochen missen
und sehen.
Nur chronisch empfehlen wir eine Nahrungsumstellung.
Was würden Sie empfehlen,
dass man diese Diagnosehypertonie auch bestellen kann?
Wenn Sie 3-mal Blutdruck messen
und 3-mal hoch sind,
ist es eine Hypertonie oder eine Diagnose-Strategie?
Wenn es 3-mal hoch ist,
dann müssen wir 3-mal Messung...
Was sagen Sie dem Patienten?
Ich denke, vor einer Woche müssen wir Druck messen
und...
...weißgitlhypertonie.
Kennen Sie das? Was ist das?
Weißgitlhypertonie.
Wegen Angst vor Erste messen wir die Blutdruck hoch.
Aber normalerweise ist es nicht hoch.
Was empfehlen Sie bei solchen Patienten,
die bei einem Arzt immer hohen Blutdruckwerte haben?
Ich würde sagen, Sie müssen früh in Praxis kommen
und man muss mindestens 30 Minuten warten.
Man kann auch zu Hause messen.
Das wollte ich hören.
Was ist für die Selbstmessung wichtig?
Da müssen Sie hinweisen
oder sagen, wie Sie richtig messen sollen.
Das, was Sie gesagt haben,
dass man im Liegenden wie messen
oder nach Sport, das müssen Sie erklären.
Wie man misst, ob man mit dem Handgelenk misst.
Besser werden diese Manschettenmessungen,
wo die Manschette angebracht werden muss.
Das ist das, was Sie sagen.
Wenn man selbst abhört,
wo man die Ausstattungskope hinhält,
müssen Sie alles zeigen.
Nur wenn es wiederholt, hohe Werte zu Hause sind
oder an drei verschiedenen Tagen in der Praxis
wieder hohe Werte gemessen sind,
haben Sie den Verdacht auf eine Atheriölehypertonie.
Das kann man auch nicht kontrollieren.
Es gibt noch für eine Alternative,
wenn Sie das nicht genau einschätzen können,
dann können Sie die Probleme haben.
Was können Sie machen?
Können die meisten Haushärzte auch machen?
Da hat jemand auch geschrieben gerade im Chat, sehe ich gerade.
Langzeit?
Ja, Langzeitprodukt.
Da kann man auch fahren, die es nachts ist zum Beispiel.
Ich habe jetzt gesagt, ich habe einen Verdacht
auf essenzielle Hypertonie.
Was kennen Sie noch einer anderen Form der Hypertonie?
Das haben Sie schon gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, bei Schlafabdö ab eine Sekundär,
das ist sekundäre Hypertonie.
Also mit anderen Krankheiten, die so Hypertonie führen.
Aus der Schlafabdö ab.
Nieren.
Was zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel Niereninsuffizienz.
Kann mal sein.
Was ist der Klassiker, wenn es von der Niere ausgeht?
Nieren, genau weiß ich nicht.
Aber Nieren hat hier ein Stenose.
Ja, das ist der Stenose.
Das ist der Stenose.
Genau weiß ich nicht.
Aber Nierenartier in Stenose.
Nierenartier in Stenose.
Das könnte sein.
Was gibt es noch für Ursachen?
Für einen haben Sie auch genannt,
diese Hypertäriose kann auch zu Bluthochdruck führen.
Was gibt es noch für Ursachen?
Für Sekundäre Hypertonie?
Pheochromostoma,
Nieren,
Adenon.
Ja, richtig.
Kann auch mal sein.
Was noch?
Atherostychlorosis, aber das ist...
Unsere Kollegen hat als Augenarzt,
Gibt es Augenurzache für Sekundäre Hypertension?
Ich kenne nur als Folge die Augenerkrankung.
Folge, ja.
Was ist...
Wir hatten ja noch mal über Medikamente gesprochen,
über Lackrez und so was.
Wir haben uns über Hypertonie gemacht.
Ganz wichtig bei Frauen zu wissen,
wo gibt es Medikamente,
die bei Frauen auf eingesetzt werden
und Hypertonie machen können.
Pille?
Ja, Pille.
Und andere Medikamente,
die zu Hypertonie machen,
was kennen Sie da?
Theruitormone,
Stereutormone, ja.
Ja, Stereute,
ja.
Das war bei Sportnähen,
wenn Sie zu viel Erythropoetin spritzen,
da kriegen Sie auch Bluthoftruck.
Genau.
Gut, das wären die Ursachen.
Bei Ihnen vermuten wir eine Essenzialhypertonie
mit den ganzen Risikofaktoren,
die Sie schon aufgezählt haben.
Und jetzt machen Sie praktisch
diese Diagnose erst mal fest,
ob es wirklich ist oder nur vorübergehend war.
Und was empfehlen Sie den Patienten,
bevor Sie ihm Medikamente geben?
Jetzt sind Sie mal Hausarzt
und Sie können sich nicht mehr
verhalten, wie er sich verhalten soll.
Damit der Bruder wieder normal ist.
Gewichtabnahme,
Nahrungsumstellung,
Rache und Karens.
Jawoll.
Und
Alkohol trinkt nicht viel.
Und dann können wir trotzdem weglassen, ja, klar.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Kaffee trinkt viel.
Woll auch reduzieren, genau.
Wenn Sie bei den Ernährungen sind,
Sie haben sich auch schon gesagt, worauf soll er aufpassen?
Salz,
Kopfsalz.
Nicht immer, aber bei den meisten.
Es gibt auch Hypertonika, die eine Hyponatremie haben.
Da muss man natürlich aufpassen
mit der Salzkarenz.
Aber beim meisten ist es Salz, ja.
Genau.
Und Bewegung haben Sie gesagt, gell.
Und was noch?
Wenn Sie an den ganzen Stressdenken haben,
wie kann er den vermeiden?
Stressvermeidung, ja.
Und die Wohnung wechseln?
Wohnung wechseln.
Oder Beruf wechseln, ja?
Beruf, nicht einfach, aber
Wohnung einfacher.
Was sind denn die Probleme bei Bluthochdruck?
Also Bluthochdruck,
Hypertonie ist eine Volkskrankheit,
wo es ja genannt ist.
Volksarzt, sehr viele Menschen,
viele Mioen Menschen.
Was ist denn das Problem an Bluthochdruck?
Es gibt ja viele Bluthochdruck-Patienten,
die gar keine Symptome haben wie er.
Was ist das Problem?
Wo hat man Angst bei Hypertonie?
Wenn es nicht behandelt,
es kann zu Herzproblemen führen.
Hypertrophik,
Erkrankung,
eine Risiko.
Was noch,
Arteriolusiklerosis,
oder ist es?
In generell Gefäßbeschädigung.
Und manchmal
Gehirnblutung, es kann
Gehirnblutung kommen.
Ja, genau.
Oder auch einen Schlaganfall,
kann auch sein.
Gefäßprobleme.
Was ist mit dem Auge?
Auge, ja, Auge,
auch Hypertansibretinopaket,
Blutungen,
Netzartblutungen.
Genau.
Und welches Organ ist noch wichtig?
Wir haben gesagt,
Herz, Gefäße, Auge, Gehirn
und auch ein Organ,
das ist bei Bluthochdruck.
Was Schaden nehmen kann
für die Hypertonie unbehandelt?
Nie.
Nieren schäden.
Deswegen muss man auch bei der Basisdiagnose,
bei Erstechnosympythonie
immer auf die Nieren gucken,
ob schon an Nieren Schaden besteht.
Es hat auch Einfluss auf die Intensität
der Medikamentdösentherapie.
Gut, haben wir ziemlich viel
gesprochen, ja?
Ja.
Können wir
Aufzeichnung
machen?
Ja, danke.